ما كان اليوم سهلا على
اسرائيل فهي المره الاولى التي تساءل فيها
امام العالم عما ترتكبه في
غزه مهمه فريقها القانوني لم تكن يسيرا
ليس لضعف في ادائه بل لقوه صوت الضحايا
وحجتهم خارج المحكمه كان التفاعل فوريا مع
مرافعات الفريق الاسرائيلي اما جنوب
افريقيا فقد كان نصيبها من المتظاهرين
الشكر والترحاب
وقد بدا بوزيرها في العدل ان حجه الفريق
الاسرائيلي اضعف من ان تسقط
الدعوه نعتقد انهم فشلوا في مواجهه او
ابطال الادله التي قدمناها للمحكمه ونعتقد
ايضا ان ليست هناك طريقه لانكار تصريحات
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ووزير
الدفاع هكذا بدا ان لاسرائيل اسبابا وجهه
للقلق فتمت رمزيه اصحاب الدعوه وثمت ايضا
ما يمكن ان يترتب
عنها لعلها المره الاولى منذ بدء هذه
الحرب يحس فيها الفلسطيني بان له صوته انا
كفلسطيني من غزه يعني اليوم بعيش لحظه
تاريخيه لاول مره يتم جلب القاده
الاسرائيليين لقاعه المحكمه العدل الدوليه
في لاهاي لمحاكمتهم على جرائم الحرب التي
يقوم فيها وجريمه الاباده الجماعيه بحق
الفلسطينيين واهالينا في قطاع غزه لكن
خساره اسرائيل قد لا تكون داخل المحكمه
فقط فثم وعي جديد حول طبيعه الصراع يتشكل
هذه السيده جاءت رفقه رضيعها تامل انه
عندما يكبر يقف مع
المظلومين جئت به لانني اعتقد انه من
المهم الوقوف من اجل حقوق الانسان واعتقد
انه من المهم البدء في سن مبكره ربما لا
يزال صغيرا لكن هكذا نتعلم
بعض من اليهود المعارضين لسياسه اسرائيل
حرصوا على الحضور ليعلنوا براءتهم مما
ترتكبه اسرائيل ويهتفوا ليس
باسمنا نحن هنا باسم شريحه واسعه من
اليهود لنعبر عن اسانا بسبب كل ما يحدث في
غزه نشعر بحرج لان ما يحدث يفترض انه يحدث
باسمنا ولان الدين اليهوديه يوظف بطريقه
خاطئه لتبرير كل هذه الجرائم
الان وقد رفعت الجلسه سيخرج القضاه
للتداول وسيكون عليهم ان يحسموا قرارهم
سريعا فما يقع في غزه لا يحتمل الانتظار
قبل ان يصدر الحكم النهائي يبدو ان
اسرائيل قد خسرت بالفعل الكثيره في هذه
المحاكمه صورتها وروايتها واخلاقيه جيشها
كما تدعي كلها تحطمت على صخره الوثائق
والصور المعروضه وتهمه الاباده الجماعيه
والكثر ا من ذلك يبدو انها في طريقها
لخساره جيل باكمله تقول استطلاعات الراي
في الغرب انه لم يعد يثق
بروايتها لكن الامر قد يتطور اكثر ثم
دعاوه اخرى رفعت امام محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه وهي على خلاف محكمه العدل التي
تحكم حصرا بين الدول يخول لها القانون
اصدار مذكرات اعتقال في حق الافراد
المدانين سيكون لقاده اسرائيل اكثر من سب
للقلق حتى لو رفضوا تنفيذ الاحكام محمد
البقالي الجزيره
هاي